Welcome to the first unit of CS258--How to Make Software Fail.
Now, making software fail is something that I feel very strongly about, but in the big picture,
it's not necessarily failures that we're interested but rather the fact that if we can find failures
in software and if we can fix these failures, then eventually we're going to run out of bugs
and we'll have a software that actually works reliably.
Now if you look at testing software as a whole--as a large problem--it's really kind of daunting,
because we can look at Microsoft's products and we can see that Microsoft didn't manage
to eliminate all the bugs in their products, and we can look at Google's services and we
can see that Google didn't manage to eliminate all the bugs in their services and so we might
want to say to ourselves--how can we possibly get rid of all the bugs in our own software.
Well, what turns out to be the case is the testing problem is not really this large monolithic problem,
but rather can be broken down into a lot of smaller sub-problems, and by looking at those
sub-problems, we can apply known techniques and things that people have done before,
and we could sort of pattern match on these problems, and once we've become good
at these smaller problems, then we can become much better testers as a whole.
And this is what Unit 1 is about.